[Musik]
guten abend hier ist heute plus mit
unserer corona sprechstunde freut mich
dass ihr dabei seid es wird gelockert
nur was wann und wo da haben die
bundesländer durchaus unterschiedliche
pläne
morgen findet wieder eine konferenz
statt mit bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
und den ministerpräsidenten wo es eben
um die lockerungen gehen soll
aber manche bundesländer wollten nicht
länger warten nicht abwarten und haben
schon vorab sich dazu geäußert wo sie
gerne am liebsten lockern würden genau
das wollen wir uns heute genauer
anschauen
und zwar mit dem virologen martin
stürmer und wie immer könnt ihr
natürlich eure fragen auch zum thema
stellen postet sie einfach hier unten in
die kommentare
jetzt aber erstmal einen überblick von
andreas hack
bayern hat einen schwerpunkt bei
gastronomie und tourismus ab 18
mai sollen biergärten öffnen dürfen
speiselokale sollen ab dem 25
mai wieder gäste empfangen können ab dem
pfingstwochenende auch hotels und
ferienwohnungen
damit will bayern hier etwas
vorsichtiger öffnen als küsten länder
wie niedersachsen
hier soll die gastronomie schon ab
kommenden montag schrittweise und unter
auflagen wieder anlaufen in mecklenburg
vorpommern sollen restaurants und
gaststätten schon kommenden samstag
wieder öffnen können ab dem 18
mai dürfen hotels pensionen und
ferienwohnungen wieder einheimische
gäste beherbergt in baden württemberg
gibt es noch keinen konkreten zeitplan
für die gastronomie dort sollen ab
montag einzel sportarten wie tennis golf
oder leichtathletik wieder möglich sein
sachsen anhalt hat die kontaktsperre
gelockert
das dürfen sich wieder bis zu fünf
menschen treffen bayern will ab morgen
zumindest die ausgangs beschränkung
zurückfahren die länder haben
unterschiedliche interessen und sie sind
unterschiedlich stark betroffen
der fraktionschef der union im bundestag
ralph brinkhaus wünscht sich ein
einheitliches vorgehen der bundesländer
und er hat noch eine kühne hoffnung dass
die telefonkonferenz mit bundeskanzlerin
merkel morgen mehr ordnung ins verfahren
bringt per skype zugeschaltet ist mir
hat der virologe martin stürner guten
abend herr stürmer größte hallo auf den
letzten punkt herrscht immer würde ich
gerne als erstes eingehen so ein
bisschen ist es ja so als hätten wir
gerade zwei lager die einen die sagen
wir wollen einheitliche regelungen die
den flickenteppich quasi verteufeln und
auf der anderen seite leute zum beispiel
auch bei uns in den kommentaren die
sagen regionale lockerungen sind
eigentlich viel sinnvoller wie sehen sie
das
ich glaube beide seiten haben haben was
für sich ich bin auch immer ein bisschen
ambivalent auf der einen seite finde ich
den fehler wenn des föderalismus sehr
gut und wir haben aber einige länder
bundesländer die haben was die
fallzahlen antrieb angesagt relativ
wenig auch pro einwohnerzahl
und dementsprechend könnten die
natürlich ganz anders agieren als zb ein
land wo wir sehr viele infektionen haben
und natürlich regional unterschiedliche
maßnahmen lockern
das macht durchaus sinn auch im zuge
dessen wie die infektion dort auch
verlaufen sind die zahlen auf der
anderen seite ist das natürlich klar
wenn das bild so uneinheitlich ist in
ganz deutschland dann wird es auch
kompliziert gerade in den grenzregionen
provoziert bei möglicherweise auch dass
leute von dem ein bundesland ins andere
fahren und so weiter und schafft sich
damit auch vielleicht wieder mehr
probleme als mein armer also es hat
beide seiten haben was für sich jetzt
haben wir ja gerade schon einige
maßnahmen gehört unter anderem dass
restaurants das war ja eigentlich was wo
alle spitzen finger hatten das lied bald
schon wieder geöffnet werden sollen was
sagen sie dazu aus biologischer sicht
ja es ist natürlich so ein bisschen ein
bisschen schwierig wenn ich irgendwo
essen gehen oder eine kneipe ist ja egal
ob restaurants cafés kneipen
da möchte ich was essen oder was trinken
in der regel und das spätestens dann
nebenbei masken und man sitzt dann am
tisch mit freunden bekannten familie wie
auch immer was denn zugelassen wird
man hat eine räumliche nähe über einen
längeren zeitraum und man hat keine
masken dazu und damit haben wir viele
schutzmechanismen die wir in den letzten
tagen versucht haben einzuhalten
außer kraft gesetzt und damit wird es
für mich so ein bisschen unbehaglich und
ich weiß noch nicht ob man das schafft
eben in restaurants dieser diese
sicherheitskonzepte vor allem in den
erforderlichen abstand
ob man ihn tatsächlich einhalten kann
jetzt sagt bayern zum beispiel die
biergärten sollen vor den restaurants
öffnen schon am 18
mai ist das ein klügeres vorgehen
einfach weil das draußen stattfindet der
grundsätzlich ist sie ist die frische
luft natürlich meine alte was anderes
szenario als der geschlossene raum weil
entsprechende andere zirkulation und und
temperaturbedingungen herrschen aber auf
der anderen seite auch im biergarten
wenn ich mich waren zurück er ist ja
auch schon ein paar tage her dass wir
einen biergarten sitzen durften kann das
doch auch teilweise ziemlich eng sein
also da muss man natürlich sehr genau
aufpassen dass im prinzip die
abstandsregelung vor allem ein
halten werden und dass wenn das
umgesetzt wird muss man halt mal schauen
wie sich das tatsächlich entwickelt ich
glaube den den trend aufhalten kann man
im augenblick erst mal nicht weil die
zahlen sich natürlich trotz allem was
auch jetzt schon gelockert worden das
recht günstig entwickelt haben jetzt
argumentieren die bundesländer zum
beispiel mecklenburg vorpommern auch mit
den niedrigen fallzahlen die sie haben
und sagen jetzt zum beispiel tourismus
den wollen wir wieder hochfahren
aber kann es nicht beim thema tourismus
den mann jetzt bundesweit dann wieder
öffnet oder besser gesagt wenn
mecklenburg vorpommern sagt bundesweit
dürfen gäste kommen wollen sie sich dann
damit ich vielleicht wieder das virus in
ihr bundesland das kann sehr gut
passieren vor allem vor dem hintergrund
dass wir ja im prinzip die dunkelziffer
immer wieder so ein bisschen aus den
augen verlieren alles was wir an fällen
zahlen diskutieren basiert auf dem was
wird positiv getestet haben und nicht
auf dem was möglicherweise ungetestet
und unerkannt bei uns noch im lande
vorhanden ist an infizierten und unter
dem aspekt ist es natürlich möglich und
oder vielleicht auch sogar
wahrscheinlich dass dementsprechend auch
wieder bundesländer die wenig fälle
haben vielleicht gerade durch solche
maßnahmen wieder mehr fälle bekommen
werden hier ist eine relativ passende
frage dazu finde ich von bei twitter und
zwar wird er gefragt warum wird dann
nicht mehr getestet
das ist eine super frage wir haben ja
eigentlich im augenblick mehr test
kapazität als tatsächlich test
angeordnet und durchgeführt werden
liegt ein bisschen auch an der fall
definition wir haben mark sollen
getestet werden alle menschen die
erkältung symptomatik aufweisen ist die
grippesaison vorbei die erkältungssaison
geht so ein bisschen raus
dementsprechend aber wahrscheinlich
relativ wenig patienten die klassische
symptome haben also könnte man natürlich
regeln sagen gut dann testen wir die die
keine symptome haben aber nach welchen
kriterien wählen wir diese diese
menschen aus die dann zum testen gehen
sollen ich glaube da gibt es von der
vorgabe her
noch keine idee wie man jetzt sozusagen
hätten sagen kann geht uns testzentrum
und du nicht weil wenn jetzt plötzlich
allem testzentren rennen dann sind wir
wieder ganz schnell da dass wir zu viele
leute oder zu viele testanforderungen
haben und könnten im notfall wenn wir
infektionsketten aufklären sollen nicht
reagieren weil die taste
kapazitäten der schaft sind also ist ein
bisschen schwierig im augenblick wir
sind schon mitten bei den test und bei
den zahlen das wollen wir uns jetzt noch
mal genauer anschauen nämlich die
aktuellen fallzahlen denn es hieß ja
auch immer gelockert wird nur dann wenn
die zahlen es eben zu lassen und ich
schaue man es jetzt mal an die
gesamtzahl der seit anfang der pandemie
infizierten und auch die zahl der
todesfälle steigen natürlich jeden tag
weiter aber viel langsamer als früher
dabei sinkt auf der anderen seite schon
seit anfang april die gesamtzahl der die
aktuell an cupid 19 erkrankt sind es
gelesen deutlich mehr menschen als neu
erkranken und die zahl der neuen
infektionen sinkt immer weiter
da wird um statistische ausrutscher an
einzelnen tagen einzufangen jeden tag
einen durchschnitt der letzten sieben
tage gerechnet und der sinkt seit vielen
wochen
heute waren es nur noch knapp über 1000
neuinfektionen abstandsregeln und
kontakt beschränkungen führen dazu dass
corona kranke immer weniger menschen
anstecken die kennzahl dafür ist derzeit
0,71
das heißt zehn erkrankte stecken im
schnitt nur noch etwa sieben neue an
auch das bedeutet die zahl der aktuell
kranken tendiert nach unten
ein sehr labiler fortschritt wie wir
wissen denn die ganze pandemie hat ja
mal mit nur einer handvoll infizierter
menschen begonnen
ja darf ich nachfragen der stürmer das
sind jetzt ganz schön viele zahlen
welche schlüsse ziehen sie daraus und
was ist jetzt eigentlich gerade aktuell
die wichtigste kennzahl ja insgesamt
erst mal ist die tendenz gab ich ein was
alle zahlen betrifft eher günstig sowohl
was die verträgliche zahl an
neuinfektionen angeht als auch die zahl
der der genesenen im vergleich zu denen
die erkrankung das ist ein günstiger
parameter und eben auch die sogenannte
die produktionszahlen es ist für mich
gibt es da in dem sie erst mal keinen
favoriten
sondern ich versuche immer die zahlen
als gesamtheit zu nehmen und mich nicht
auf eine einzige zahl zu konzentrieren
das wie gesagt im gesamtbild glaube ich
dass wir tatsächlich sehr günstig da
stehen und
denke auch dass auf basis dieser
geschichten auch weitere lockerungen
durchaus diskutiert werden kann
genau daran wird orientiert und ich
schaue immer in die kommentare da kommen
wir euch direkt auch eine frage dazu
wenn ihr jetzt wieder die fallzahlen
steigen werden dann die gleichen
maßnahmen wieder angewendet oder werden
sogar strengere maßnahmen ergriffen das
können sie natürlich nicht beantworten
ich würde das vielleicht mal erweitern
und würde sagen also was wir schon
wissen oder was man jetzt also was wir
schon wissen ist dass sich die politik
dann natürlich daran orientiert jetzt
soll angela merkel sich auch so geäußert
haben dass sie so eine fallzahl
obergrenze für neuinfektionen haben
möchte mehrere medien berichten darüber
dass denn in einem landkreis innerhalb
von sieben tagen mehr als 35
neuinfektionen auf 100000 einwohner zu
verzeichnen sind das dann die
lockerungen zurückgenommen werden
hersteller halten sie das für sinnvoll
so eine zahl von 35 personen am sieben
tage 100.000 einwohner
ja das ist problem ist natürlich man
muss es oder wenn man das machen will
muss man sich irgendwo daran festhalten
ich weiß nicht ob ich das so strikt an
so einer starken grenze machen würde ich
habe ihnen schon gesagt für mich sind
verschiedene parameter entscheidend und
ich würde das nicht an einem einzelnen
parameter unbedingt festmachen wollen
soll ich würde mir im trends in
verschiedenen verschiedenen ebenen
angucken das ist natürlich schwieriger
zu kommunizieren so eine zahl 35 das ist
plakativ und einfach und nachvollziehbar
aber mir wäre das zu zu zu starrer
letztendlich und wenn man jetzt über
über die frage wie würde man damit
umgehen wenn diese zahlen entsprechen
diese grenze wieder überschritten wird
ich glaube aktuell könnte man noch ein
bisschen einschätzen weil es die
problemkinder also sprich welche
lockerungen das problem der steigenden
zahlen verursacht hat wenn ich mir jetzt
angeguckt habe im ersten beitrag was
alles gelockert wird und wie viel und
wenn man das alles berücksichtigen
wollen und haben dann steigen da wird
sehr sehr schwierig einzelner maßnahmen
zu identifizieren die schuldig sein
könnten in anführungszeichen schuldig
und dann kann es passieren dass waren
dann massiv wieder zu machen müsste es
gibt ja diese angst vor einer zweiten
welle
dazu hat sich heute auch rrk präsident
lothar wieler geäußert und dann haben
wir mal kurz rein war es aber wichtig
ist und das möchte ich auch noch mal
betonen
das ist eine pandemie und bei einer
pandemie wird dieses virus so lange im
krankheits bereich sein und krankheiten
hervorrufen bis 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung infiziert sind
darum wissen wir dass es mit großer
sicherheit eine zweite welle gibt die
die mehrheit der wissenschaftler ist
sich dessen sicher und man geht auch
davon aus dass eine dritte welle
herrscht immer wenn jetzt lothar wieler
hier von einer zweiten oder dritten
welle spricht was meint er damit
eigentlich genau meint er damit
steigende fallzahlen zum beispiel
nächste woche oder meint er damit so
eine richtig neue welle in ein paar
monaten
ja ich glaube dass diese szenarien sehr
unterschiedlich erfahrungs zu sehen oder
berechnet werden müssten
nehmen wir mal an die die maßnahmen der
lockerungen die wir jetzt durchführen
ist zu viel und wir kriegen wieder sehr
viel sehr schnell steigende zahlen und
wir machen nicht rechtzeitig wieder
komplett zu dann kannst du uns passieren
dass wir jetzt relativ zeitnah eine eine
große zweite welle bekommen also sehr
viel starke sehr viel stärker steigende
fallzahlen und das wäre sozusagen das
worst case szenario das wir jetzt akut
was bekommt grundsätzlich wenn man jetzt
ein bisschen den fuß auf der bremse
lassen dass gemäßigt beobachten die
fallzahl entwicklung die verschiedene
parameter immer gut im blick haben dann
wird sich letztendlich natürlich dass
wir uns nicht ganz zurück drängen lassen
und spätestens dann wenn wir uns wieder
in die klassische erkältungssaison
begeben wird wahrscheinlich auch das
corona videos das neue cola virus wieder
deutlicher mit nach oben gehen weil
impfstoffe werden wir frühestens
wahrscheinlich dass im nächsten jahr
bekommen und herren immunität werden wir
mit den aktuell getroffenen maßnahmen
definitiv nicht zeitnah erreichen
sie sprechen schon herren immunität an
ich möchte aber noch einmal kurz
nachfragen bei der zweiten welle kommt
er fragen von lydia bei youtube gefragt
wieso heißt es so oft dass die zweite
welle viel schlimmer sein wird ja wir
haben am anfang des
unsere des ausbruchsgeschehens in
deutschland also das jetzt abgesehen von
den ersten fall zahlen die wir gehabt
haben haben wir hotspots gehabt wir
haben die reiserückkehrer aus den
skigebieten gehabt wie in süddeutschland
sehr große fallzahlen besorgt haben und
wir haben in nordrhein westfalen den
ausbruch gehabt und das hat sich dann
ein bisschen in der republik verbreitet
und da nicht das problem dass wir
möglicherweise eben nicht lokale
ausbruchsgeschehen haben sondern dass
wir bundesweit werde bekommen die dann
letztendlich die fallzahlen deutlich
nach oben spülen können und deutlich
höher als was wir am anfang gehabt haben
wo wir eigentlich eher so drei bis vier
hot spots gehabt haben das ist das
problem was aber aktuell haben gefragt
so sie bei youtube zum beispiel dass ihr
die infizierten sorgen machen bei denen
man es eben nicht erkennen könnte sich
das virus nicht unbemerkt weit
verbreiten bevor wir es bemerken
ja natürlich wenn wir jetzt mal die
heinsberg studie uns angucken da haben
sie ja gesagt die kollegen das ist über
20 symptomatischen patienten
identifiziert haben das heißt ein
fünftel der infizierten merkt es nicht
dass sie erkrankt sind und verbreiten
natürlich das virus weiter das ist etwas
was man auf jeden fall im hinterkopf
behalten sollte das aber sehr schwierig
zu identifizieren
letztendlich kann man nur dann aktiv
werden wenn man ein sehr gutes
monitoring also wenn man plötzlich
auftretender gerade im sommer plötzlich
auftretende erkältungs erkrankungen
sieht dann relativ schnell von
behördenseite die person identifiziert
die entsprechende getestet werden dann
hat man vielleicht die chance geben
diese diese übertragung einzugrenzen und
zu identifizieren ansonsten gebe ich
gebe ich dir recht dieser
symptomatischen patienten sind für uns
durchaus ein problem sie haben gerade
schon die herren immunität angesprochen
tatsächlich kam hier auch fragen dazu
von unterschiedlichen nutzern und zwar
einmal bei youtube sollten wir bei so
wenig neuinfektionen jetzt nicht
absichtlich die menschen infizieren
und hier kommt noch eine
was spricht dagegen die maßnahmen in
kleinen schritten so weit zu lockern
bis wir eine annähernd der auslastung in
den krankenhäusern erreichen das ziel
dabei das auf herdenimmunität genau das
das problem ist wir haben ja schon
mehrfach vorschläge gehört dass man
sozusagen die risikogruppe stärker
isoliert und die nicht risikogruppe sich
durch infizieren lässt weil sie eben
seltener schwer krank werden
jetzt ist natürlich immer die frage wo
hört man eine risikogruppe auf wo fängt
sie haben ist das nur alters gibt oder
spielt ja auch so was wie eine diabetes
oder bluthochdruck eine rolle als
risikogruppe zu zählen oder eine
allergie asthma bei den haben nämlich
eine sehr große risiko proben eine sehr
kleine profi kein risiko hat das ist das
eine
wenn ich die risikogruppe sich komplett
durch infizieren lassen und selbst wenn
ist es werden immer noch ein paar
millionen menschen in diesem land sein
und selbst wenn davon nur ein bruchteil
einen schweren verlauf hat wird das
wahrscheinlich unsere krankenhäuser
wieder überlassen wir haben jetzt die
günstige situation eben weil wir so
restriktiv zu gemacht haben dass wir den
krankenhäusern freie betten haben aber
das kann sich sehr schnell ändern wenn
eben entsprechend hohe anzahl an
menschen sich infiziert und da können
wir auch nicht genau was die zweite
frage angeht wie will man das machen
sich so viel infizieren zu lassen dass
die betten gerade mal so belegt endlich
das ist letztendlich gar nicht steuerbar
das kann man auch nicht vorhersagen wie
sich das letztendlich dann entwickelt
und natürlich auch ein gewisses risiko
hier kommt eine frage bei youtube passt
ganz gut dazu nämlich die frage gibt es
neue erkenntnisse zu langzeitschäden
auch das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt
langzeit ist ein dehnbarer begriff wir
kennen die erkrankung im prinzip seit
anfang des jahres das heißt vier volle
monate die wir uns letztendlich mit dem
virus der an sich und den
krankheitsbildern auseinandersetzen
können wir wissen noch nicht wirklich
sehr viel was das virus sozusagen
dauerschäden möglicherweise angerichtet
hat immer nur ein beispiel die die den
verlust von geschmack und geruch ist das
jetzt
60 nur eine blockade eines sogenannten
rezeptors in unserem mund oder
rachenraum gewesen dass sozusagen der
siebel also vollkommen wiederhergestellt
wird
oder hat sich da doch in den nerven
irgendetwas verändert dass
möglicherweise dauerschäden bleiben
das weiß man noch nicht genau und es
kann natürlich passieren dass auch
jemand wie ich das virus eigentlich ohne
große komplikationen die virus
erkrankung durchgemacht hat vielleicht
doch irgendwo ein schaden zurück
geblieben hat den ich jetzt noch gar
nicht merke also da müssen wir noch ein
bisschen geduld haben das ist durchaus
nicht unwahrscheinlich dass da
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was
nachkommt wir machen gerade erst unsere
ersten erfahrungen quasi wenn man jetzt
mal in andere länder schaut wenn wir
noch mal zurückkommt zu den lockerungen
um die es ja morgen gehen soll jetzt
haben andere länder ja schon zb
österreich früher als wir deutlicher
gelockert was sind denn da bisher für
erfahrungen gemacht worden
in österreich hat auf einer anderen
fallzahl basis lockern können wenn man
sich da die die zahlen und die
entwicklung angucken hat zb die die
neuinfektionsrate die täglichen
infektionsrate bei unter umwelt gelegen
das ist natürlich eine ganz andere basis
als als in deutschland
wobei natürlich auch von der
einwohnerzahl das sicherlich auch eine
andere andere dimension letztendlich ist
ja die erfahrung scheinen dort auch gut
zu sein also man man ließ zumindest und
sie zumindest keinen signifikanten
wiederanstieg also insofern kann man
wenn man kontrolliert und unter
vernünftigen bedingungen lockert also
durchaus auch die pandemie und die
verbreitung des virus weiter gut
kontrollieren das ist aber die
hauptaufgabe die letztendlich unsere
politik wirklich gewährleisten muss dass
die maßnahmen die sie diese wie sie
treffen dass die dafür sorgen dass sich
das virus nicht weiter verbreitet also
da für mich das wichtigste
weiterhin den abstand einhalten zu
können die distanz zu wahren
all diese maßnahmen werden ja im prinzip
nicht nötig wenn wir wirklich im
impfstoff hätten danach wird ja gerade
mit unter hochdruck gearbeitet
da kommt eine frage von andy bei youtube
wäre es nicht ausreichend nur
freiwillige impfungen für die
risikogruppe zu empfehlen wenn es denn
dann impfung gibt wieso muss es denn
unbedingt herdenimmunität sein also
warum die ganze bevölkerung impfen das
ist jetzt quasi eine frage die weit in
die zukunft geht
naja was will man erreichen es ist
natürlich vollkommen richtig wenn wir
uns die influenza situation auch wenn
man die beiden erreger jetzt gar nicht
vergleichen sondern einfach nur mal
dieses szenario und die immunität
seminarien vergleichen möchte da ist
tatsächlich die impfung nur für die
risikogruppen empfohlen also die älteren
menschen und grunderkrankung und da sind
natürlich wenn sich junge menschen
infizieren können natürlich das virus
eben weiter verbreiten also die idee die
man natürlich mit der immunität
verbinden möchte wäre dass die pandemie
und dass die verbreitung des virus zum
erliegen kommt weil wenn ausreichend
menschen immun sind gegen das virus dann
kann es sich nicht weiter verbreiten und
die die ganze welle wird letztendlich
verhelfen
und deswegen ist im augenblick die idee
möglichst viele menschen zu impfen um
das ganze gewährleisten zu können wie
sich das letztendlich entwickeln wird in
der bevölkerung und wie die
impfbereitschaft sein wird das werden
wir sehen wie gesagt die influenza als
ein gutes beispiel da könnte man gegen
thun unter impfen sich leider immer
wieder noch zu wenig und wir sehen ja
auch immer wieder heftige welt mit
vielen toten also das wird noch eine
spannende diskussion in der zukunft wenn
der impfstoff wirklich da ist wie er
denn auch in der bevölkerung akzeptiert
wird absolut einen diskussion die dann
auf kommen wir vielleicht sprechen wir
dann auch wieder hoffentlich in ein paar
monaten zu diesem thema und jetzt erst
mal an dieser stelle ganz herzlichen
dank herr stürmer für das gespräch ja so
gerne und ganz herzlichen dank natürlich
auch an euch für die ganzen fragen die
kommentare die gekommen sind aber auch
fürs zuschauen
ich wünsche euch einen schönen abend
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann interessiert euch
vielleicht auch dieser hier
da ging es darum wie es in der korona
zeit mit der bundesliga weiter gehen
kann oder ihr klickt ihr da könnt ihr
euch einfach alle unsere corinna
sprechstunden anschauen oder ihr lasst
uns hier einfach ein abo da das wird uns
sehr freuen